Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live.
I am Rawkode, your host also known as
David McKay but all the good handles were
taken unfortunately.
I wanna thank my employer, Equinix Medal. They
afford me time
to invest and to producing these shows and
getting you know, experts around the world to
come and introduce us to all of their
fantastic software. So thank you Equinix metal. If
you wanna try out Equinix metal, can use
the code Rawkode live. This will get you
$50
of compute time.
You can splash that in a few hours
with 400 gig of ram and 96 cores
or more or you can be a little
bit more conservative and have that run for
up to ten hours or a couple of
days depending on the machine and hardware that
you use. So check that out. It's good
to have a fun.
We also have a Discord channel if you
want to continue this conversation or you're not
watching this live and have questions. You can
find that at Rawkodelive/chat.
Now today we're gonna be taking a look
at Linkerd,
a cloud native service mesh by Buoyant
And we are very lucky that today we
have
Thomas, Thomas Rampelberg from Buoyant himself who's gonna
guide us through our Linkerd journey. Hello, Thomas.
How are you?
I am doing fantastic.
So excited to be here.
Awesome. Do you wanna just
tell us a little bit about what you
do at at Buoyant?
Yeah. You bet. I'm a software engineer at
Buoyant.
Buoyant's kind of the creators of the service
mesh. Linkerd version one was the first original
one. We went through a pretty big rewrite
based off of everything we've learned from version
one, and, we've got Linkerd two, which is
the
product that we're gonna be talking about today.
And I do software engineering and help maintain
that.
Awesome.
Now service mesh might be a new term
to some of the people that we have
watching. So can we maybe just break that
down a little bit and say what are
some of the responsibilities for a service mesh?
Yeah. You bet. So
let's talk a little bit about
how it all got started.
Back in the day at Twitter, they kinda
started out as a monolith
giant Ruby on Rails application. And as the
organization scaled and
folks got more and more frustrated with the
fail whale, they needed to go split out
into microservices.
Once you start splitting out into microservices,
there's these concerns that pretty much everybody needs
to go and implement.
You need to have a common
observable
observability stacks. You need to have metrics that
are the same across all the microservices, whatever
language they're written in. You need to have
reliability
concerns,
retries,
time outs, routing decisions,
smart load balancing,
and you need to have security,
so MTLS.
Those three things
at Twitter, they created a library called Finagle
to
implement that because they were writing all of
their microservices in a single language, Scala.
But most organizations who do microservices, one of
the big wins there is that you get
to write in whatever language you want. And
so,
Linkerd, the first service mesh, was kind of
created as a way to go and pull
all of the
we're gonna call them operational concerns,
like security and reliability and, metrics out of
developers'
apps and into a proxy that the operators
can go and deploy. And so Linkerd two
basically does that. It is a sidecar proxy
that gets deployed alongside your application
and that
goes and provides all of those benefits. The
sidecar proxy is what we call a data
plane, and then there's a control plane that
goes and manages all of the service discovery
and policy enforcement. And then all of that
runs on top of the Kubernetes platform itself.
Wow.
It does a lot. So that's awesome.
I always think like when, you know, I'm
talking to people about why they should be
cloud native or why they should adopt micro
services and you know, one of the common
themes that comes up is people say that
it simplifies the code that they write. Like
they get to write smaller services
that do very small things, but what they
don't realize is that all they're doing is
moving that complexity down to the infrastructure layer,
down to the network layer and that's why
tools like Kubernetes and Linkerd are just so
important when it comes to these new these
new microservice architectures or cloud native architectures.
You're
totally getting me set up for a rant.
Microservices in my opinion don't actually solve a
technology problem. They solve a human problem. The
whole purpose of microservices is to go and
give teams inside organizations ownership of their own
destiny. So it's not about, like, writing little
tiny pieces of code because you're exactly right.
That little tiny piece of code that runs
as a single service may be easy, but
now you need to think about all the
interconnections there. And
if you go and write a thousand microservices,
you've got a thousand x the complexity of
just shoving it into one place. Yep. Exactly.
I love that, the human problem line. I'm
gonna steal that. I borrow it, of course.
I credit you. Please do. I think more
folks need to hear it. And it's a
very important problem to solve. It it's very
powerful. It's the problem, to your point, that
all of the cloud native solutions solve is
giving teams and developers control over their own
destiny, but it's a human problem. Yeah. Definitely.
So
let's you know, that let's this stream is
all about getting hands on and showing the
technology and and how it works. So let
me cover
the,
there we go. Let me cover where we
are. So
with our stream I do very little upfront,
but of course we do need a few
things in advance for this. We want to
focus on the Linkerd aspects and nothing else.
So in order for that, I have used
Equinix metal and the cluster API and I
provisioned us two Linkerd clusters, Linkerd one and
Linkerd two, not very imaginative naming, but hopefully
something I would forget.
That's it. That's all I've done. Everything else
we're gonna do live and we're gonna do
it now.
Now I also have the Linkerd homepage here
and I'm assuming like everyone always does, they
tell me let's go to the docs. So
what is step one for getting started with
Linkerd on
Kubernetes?
Let's go hit that getting started link there
and
hopefully it will be self explanatory.
I knew you were gonna say that, but
I always ask it. I always ask. Alright.
So I'm I'm not gonna run cube control
version. I'm pretty confident with that.
In order to Actually,
is your cluster 119 or 118?
It's 119 Dot 3.
Oh,
I should've asked this before.
We'll have you use we'll have you use
the edge.
The TLDR there is that, Kubernetes one
nineteen
has some interesting
upgrades because of Golang, and certificates don't work
quite the way that they should. So if
you see that step one install command there,
instead of doing run Linkerd install, add a
dash edge to the end of the the
install, and we'll get you a edge version
that will work.
For those who are paying attention here, our
edges are unstable versions. But
as of probably this week, we'll have a
new stable version coming out
based off of our unstable. So you'll be
seeing the latest and greatest here.
Well, we do like to live life on
edge here, literally. So
oh, I need to change this. So you
want me to add Yep. Dash Edge just
on the URL? Nope. On the
Install Edge. Fix that. Yep. That's it.
Okay. So let's see if I can run
Linkerd version.
This is a
COBRA. So yep. Alright. Edge twenty ten six.
So I think we're over the first hurdle.
We're now running the Edge one.
Okay. So
now recommending that I run a Linkerd check
pre. So what what does this do? What's
what's it looking for?
So we're just gonna validate that your cluster
is
all
ready to get Linkerd installed on it. A
lot of that's going to be
RBAC and making sure that you've not got
any crazy settings on your cluster.
We're we feel pretty strongly in our check
infrastructure.
As I'm sure you've probably noticed, Kubernetes clusters
tend to be a little bit of snowflakes.
Everyone is different.
Even though we say that it's all cattle,
it's not.
Clusters are pets. And so we like to
make sure that folks know that Linkerd can
get running on their cluster right away.
So if that comes back and tells us
that our cluster is not applicable, we're just
packing up and going to the pub. Right?
That's
I could I could go for the pub.
Looks like we're getting texts. I'm sorry, mate.
We're ever stuck here. Okay. So
status checks are all green.
So
this is just creating the Kubernetes API, checking
the Kubernetes versions and making sure that our
back permissions are in place that it can
create a proven it needs. Yep.
And I see net admin and net raw,
which I guess makes sense as a service
mesh. We've got some networking stuff that has
to happen so. Yep.
Okay.
So then we go through the Linkerd install
and we're just gonna apply that straight to
Kubernetes, which is going to install, I'm assuming,
our Linkerd control plane and data plane?
Just the control plane, though. The control plane
uses the data plane.
Okay.
And then that command, Linkerd install, just outputs
YAML. So if you so felt like auditing
or taking a look at that, you could.
And this is kind of meant for
kicking the tires and getting started.
As you asked before the stream gets started,
there is a Helm chart that you can
use. But like most things, Helm, it takes
a while to go figure out what settings
you want and how to configure it. So
we kinda recommend getting started with this and
then figuring out where you wanted to go
for a production install.
Yeah. I I can see there's there's obviously
quite a lot going on here with this
kind of quick start approach.
Grafana,
there's
proxy injectors, Linkerd web, so I'm assuming we've
got some sort of dashboard or UI.
Yep. Lots of lots of stuff for us
to poke and play with which is good.
Alright. Let's see. So we now have this
command. So this is no longer the precheck,
but it's now gonna make sure that what
we've just applied
works.
Exactly.
And we're gonna sit and wait while the
con containers come up.
It's
pretty frustrating to go and
try and run through the get started guide
and not have everything ready yet.
It'll be alright. I mean,
it's it's good to see that stuff running.
So,
I mean there's not a not exciting television
but people have to see what happens here
and you know what, I love it when
it fails. Don't get me wrong, see when
the docs are great and it works and
we just we go through it, cool. I
love intuitive docs, I love it when I
don't have to think but at the same
time when things break, it's also good to
be able to dig in and see what's
actually happening under the hood so. Totally.
But we're out of luck even on our
Linkerd Edge release here, we're still just getting
this little green tick everywhere we go.
Alright. Let's keep going.
I'm done.
Right?
Yep. You have a working install.
So if I just run, I won't bother
with ampersand.
This is gonna do some sort of port
forward, I presume.
Yep. It's opened in the wrong That
that is actually literally just a wrapper around
kubectl port forward. We actually use that code.
So
Alright. Okay. Yeah. It keeps it nice and
simple for people with a link of DCLI.
So I get that. Yep. So this is
a dashboard.
It's just showing me
my is this like a Kubernetes dashboard? I
see that it showed me cron jobs and
daemon size deployments. I mean, is this Linkerd
specific or what's going on here? Yeah. So
this is Linkerd specific.
Because the control plane
dog food's the data plane itself, if you
go click on that Linkerd
but or Linkerd link there, you'll actually see
the full health of what's happening in the
control plane right now, including the service topology
and all of the deployments. And so you've
switched over to Linkerd namespace now.
You could go click on deployments.
We keep it super close to the Kubernetes
dashboard
so that it's easy to understand what's going
on, but it is Linkerd specific
functionality.
And then,
while this is super Linkerd specific,
we also have Grafana links,
if you notice that
link right there that you can go to
for prebuilt dashboards. So if you wanted to
put this up on a TV,
something like that, you can do that as
well.
Alright. There's
a lot then. Right? So this quick start
installer has given me Linkerd running on my
cluster as a surface mesh. Yep. But it's
also got a Grafana, which we've seen an
install. It's get I'm assuming there's then Prometheus
being deployed also. That's how the metrics are
getting from Linkerd into
the Grafana and you're deploying all of these
pre canned dashboards.
Yep. I guess, to give me confidence that
Linkerd is doing what I expected to do.
Right? Exactly.
I I believe pretty strongly in
letting folks validate what they just got done
doing and making sure that it's all healthy.
And so that's kinda how we get to
this point here.
Okay. I mean, this is pretty sweet. I
like in this.
So I'm assuming that
by looking at this, I mean, there's not
really anything running in my cluster yet. So
Yeah. Right. This this is just Linkerd
set an idle test at a certain degree?
Mhmm. Okay.
So if I I'm just I'm just gonna
guess that maybe there's demo app, but there
is a demo app. So Sure enough.
No. I kinda skipped over a step there.
I'm gonna assume it's maybe not important. This
is just
That's pretty fun to take a look at.
Pull it up, and we can chat a
little bit about it.
Okay. Can I close the port forward, or
should I leave that open? Or Nah.
So we come with a tool what is
this? Top?
This is top. So we come with a
tool called top,
and this is
watching all of the communications in the cluster
live
and then showing you the top of what's
happening in the cluster. And so you'll see
each,
path, the source, destination. And so this is
a fun way to kinda take a look
at what's going on inside the cluster. Here,
you'll see that,
the the Linkerd installed Prometheus is going and
scraping a whole bunch of deployments.
Those IP addresses are actually kubelets going and
doing readiness and liveness checks as you can
see by ready and ping. And so
as the scrapes and the rest of that
happens, you'll see these go up,
with success rate and all the data. So
this is kind of a fun thing to
pull up if you are
doing a deployment or something like that. You
can kinda watch the health of what's going
on as the deployment goes out in real
time.
Awesome.
So
let me throw a few questions at you
then. Because I'm I'm I'm curious like like
right now what role Linkerd is playing in
this in this idle state. Like,
we're not injecting a SAICAR into anything that
is preexisting in my cluster. Is is that
right? Correct. Your your cluster is working the
way
it should be
specifically because
the service mesh goes and gets
part of the data path.
And,
let's be honest,
service meshes aren't perfect software, and so stuff
is gonna break. And and we
really, really encourage folks to do things incrementally.
And so kind of where you're going with
this, I think, is just add it to
one workload and then slowly roll it out
on your cluster. So we try pretty hard
not to touch or modify anything until you
are ready to opt into it. Yeah. I
think you've read my mind to a certain
degree there. What I'm thinking is, you know,
not a lot of people are in a
position like this where they're they have this
fresh cluster, they're deploying their workloads with the
service mesh already preexisting. So like,
I can take a very heavy production based
cluster add Linkerd to it with probably not
too much of an overhead and then slowly
start to roll out those sidecars wherever it
maybe makes sense or wherever the priority for
retries and all the other features comes in
and just Exactly. Take my time with it.
Right? Yep. Okay.
So
let's get this demo app deployed then.
So emoji photo
and we're gonna curl
and apply.
And this is just a
gRPC app that's got a couple microservices in
it, and we'll be able to walk through
how to go and diagnose an issue because
we've actually got a bug in the application.
Intentionally?
Or Intentionally. Yep. Yeah. Okay. It's
pretty fun to go and see how easy
it is to track down issues that were
something that would take you forever before Linkerd.
We had one Linkerd user who, rolled out
a service,
and it was
order of magnitude slower. No one could figure
out what was going on, and they, just
ran top. And sure enough, there was the
endpoint that was going slow. And so that,
you know, got them to the exact piece
of code they needed to change within, you
know, five or ten minutes.
Awesome.
Alright. So let's do the port forward and
see what we're playing with then.
Okay. Let's see.
So
Yep. I get to vote on my
favorite emoji.
Yep. And the the
spoiler here is that the bug is the
donut emoji. If you try and vote for
that, it will give you think it's a
four zero four.
Yep. Yeah. Okay.
But any other emoji, let's do I mean,
everybody likes the monkey. There we go.
Where's the
So we've got a voice in here. So
we've got a load generator that is going
and voting pretty much randomly so that you
can go and see the data that's going
through instead of having to generate
one or two requests yourself.
Okay. That makes sense. Okay. So that these
are just gonna arbitrarily go up then as
that load generator is applying the the fake
votes. Okay.
So
we've identified the bug and the donut. Right?
Is that the next step? Are you gonna
show me how we we we resolve this?
I think so. Let's go back to the
docs. We should it should walk us through
what's going on there. We don't need docs.
We'll make Ah,
that's right. So we haven't actually we added
EmojiVoto, but we haven't actually added,
Linkerd to it yet. So what you're using
is the unmatched service. And so the next
step here is for us to add Linkerd
in.
And to do that, we're just going to
get the YAML directly from the cluster.
Obviously, this is a demo. I wouldn't do
this in production or anything like that. And
then we're gonna run the Linkerd inject.
And, yeah, why don't you just cut and
paste that because
what this is gonna show off is the
only thing that inject does by default is
add that annotation right there, that Linkerd inject
enabled,
which is then going to go and hit
the proxy injector and have when the pods
are created on the Kubernetes cluster,
the proxy
and the in its in a container will
get added on.
Okay. So it's just that one annotation? It's
it's not an NF analysis? Yep. And so
you can add that yourself if you so
felt like it.
Inject, we'll do a manual inject as well.
If you're in an environment where mutating webhooks
don't work for you, you can go and
add it directly into the pod spec there.
But
for most folks, we recommend the
injection
proxy injector kinda process there.
Alright. So we'll we'll just go ahead and
apply that then.
And
cool.
So I injected the okay. So there's there's
four different no.
Yeah. Four different deployments and they've each been
injected. So if I run get the place.
Emoji photo namespace. Emoji photo.
And I'm just gonna just scrape
a pod and
grab the first one.
Let me just see the sidecar should be
there. Is that right? Yep.
Linkerd proxy.
Okay.
So now less traffic, if I do the
I'm gonna assume it's gonna tell me to
put forward again. Or not. It's telling me
to oh, we've got a checker. Alright. Let's
do that. Even
more checks. So you've checked control plane. Now
let's check the data plane and make sure
that that is phoning home and everything's working
there, which it is now. So that's great.
So these check commands, right, they obviously give
me a little bit of confidence and that
the changes I'm doing are are doing what
I'm doing. Do these have other applications and
production workloads to check that things are going
on or is it really just for this
this walk through?
That's a really great question.
They were kind of originally
made
for interactive,
someone setting the cluster up and working around
and doing it.
But quite a few folks,
I'm sorry.
Let me fiddle with this for a second
here.
Quite a few folks
use it in production as health checks as
well. And so it can be used for
both.
Yeah. That was kind of my my my
vibe is I ran that. It's like it
would obviously be quite nice. But, I mean,
these check things obviously have a lot of
logic to understand that Linkerd is healthy. So
maybe I could continuously run them every half
an hour and hour, make sure my my
cluster is is Linkerd happy to a certain
point. We actually have an open issue at
the moment to add a JSON
endpoint on the control plane to let you
kind of automate this whole part of the
process, which I'm pretty excited to see land.
Okay. Cool.
So what let what does this Linkerd stat
deploy command?
Run it, let's see what gets output.
So that is the golden signals,
of
your deployments. The Google SRA handbook says that
a golden signal is kinda the most important
thing to pay attention to. If you've gotta
monitor something, you should monitor the golden signals.
And those are success rate,
RPS,
and latency.
In particular, p 99 is kind of the
latency that you wanna measure. P 99 means
the ninety ninth percentile of latency. So if
you take the average,
which is p 50,
what you're gonna do is end up missing
quite a bit of latency. Your p 99
is gonna be pretty sensitive, and so users
run into that,
you know, ninety ninth percentile slow kind of
latency. You'll know about it immediately.
But
as you can see here,
we've actually got success rate issues because of
our donut emoji.
Yeah. I see that. The 83% success on
voting and the 91 on the web. So
this is our error. Now And without
Linkerd,
you would kind of be up to a
user giving you a phone call and saying,
hey. This isn't working. What's going on?
And because it's a user, they probably wouldn't
tell you that it was the donut emoji
or that the web was the app was
broken or, you know, all kinds of stuff.
And this gives you a pretty easy, again,
way to go look and immediately figure out
what's going on there.
Okay.
That that's nice. So I'm gonna throw something
out there. Don't know if it's gonna come
up another part and we should just I'm
just being impatient. But right now I'm thinking
the load generator that the quick start is
deployed here. Can can we wrap that up?
Does that come later?
What do you mean? Like, it's generating load,
but not a lot. Can we, like, have
it Oh, sure.
I mean, we could scale that deployment up.
Alright. Okay. Should we do that now, or
should we will we stick to the the
script that that We can do it now
if you wanna take a look at that.
I don't see any reason why not. I'm
just curious. So if I do all
pods
It's in VoteBot.
So if you just do a, you know,
scale replicas on VoteBot to Okay. Okay.
Emojiboto.
I just added a deployment.
I can never remember the scale command. What
is it? Scale
emoji.
Deploy
emoji
or deploy vote dash bot.
Vote
replica SQL. A dash dash replicas.
Yeah. Yeah.
Like I said, I never remember the skill
command. I always end up just gonna end
modifying the spec. But, alright. Let's see. Well,
have we got one just now? Yep. Yeah.
We've got one pod, two containers. Let's
how brave are we doing? Let's do 10.
And I'm a run emoji photo, get pods.
Let's see.
So have I run our
stat command?
So we'll see the RPS go up here,
but the stat command is based off of
Prometheus. And so there's about a sixty second
lag between
when you do something and when you actually
see it. If you were to do a
top here, you would see the
rate go up pretty much immediately.
What was that top Just do a top
deploy.
And so you can see here that there's
quite a few
requests coming in now.
Okay.
Well, I can be patient and wait for
our stack command to update.
So But there we go. We've got it
up to almost 20 r p s now.
Alright. Remind me before we finish the scale
up to like a thousand or something just
for
Nothing good.
Yeah.
Okay. So we ran the top deploy
and then we're going to run a Linkerd
tap.
Mhmm. Let's
wrong copy.
So TAP
is like
Wireshark
for your cluster. So this is the live
requests as they're going through the service mesh.
And the
big use there would be that you can
actually get all of the details that you
wanted on what's failing pretty quickly.
Tap,
will also do full headers, and so you
could go and look into, you know, the
actual headers that are going through for these
requests, go do even more debugging.
Ah, okay. Cool. So we can actually see
every single thing that's happening on the Mhmm.
The network. Nice. Okay. Yep.
And it's also available in the dashboard. So
Exactly.
Yeah. We can probably pop open the dashboard
in Grafana once we've wonderful. We've done it.
Yep. That's it. That's pretty much it. So
how do we identify the donut
problem? So you could do a
tap and just grep for a
status that's, like, four zero four.
That should
might be a 500.
Try a 500.
I was wondering. Do we also have no.
Was gonna say There it goes. Have to
wait for a donut vote, but we have
five hundreds coming through. Okay. Yep. And so,
you know, that pretty much tells you right
there that
those requests are failing
both on the outside and the inside on
the proxy.
And you could then look at the logs
here, which has the paths, and figure out
what's happening there.
Alright. Nice.
So that's our demo application finished.
Yep. So can we
use this demo application to explore some of
the other features that Linkerd brings to the
table?
We
might need to install different
depending on which way way we wanna go.
We can go look at,
let's
go through the
smorgasbord,
and I'll let you pick pick your own
adventure here.
We could do,
take a look at tracing, which is kind
of interesting. We could go look at
retries and timeouts. Maybe the easiest thing to
do would be a look at TLS
and how that's been automatically set up. I
don't think we'll need a new demo app
for that.
Some other fun stuff to look at
would be
retries and timeouts,
or perhaps the most interesting one of all
would be chatting a little bit about canary
rollouts, why they're important, and how Linkerd helps
you out there.
But those are all kinda good.
Yeah. There's there's pretty much we could just
go through every feature if we had the
time. But let's let's cherry pick them. Why
don't we because I think we've got you
know, we have access to this Grafana and
a dashboard setup and I'd like us to
be able to see how we can use
that. So what if we start with something
hopefully easy, I'm making some assumptions here. But
what if we just do fall injection and
start making things break and then see what
happens in our dashboard for you? Sure.
Okay.
I don't know what happened there. Okay. So
I should probably click on the feature. Is
that gonna take me to the docs?
Yeah. We and we've got a tutorial for
that.
Alright. So
But this is a different demo application that
we'll need to install.
That's okay. We've got a we can do
that. So this is just gonna create a
Bix app namespace and deploy Bix app thing.
So let's just let that go.
And if you scroll up, actually, you'll be
able to see a picture of what the
architecture looks like a little bit more. So
there's the architecture for this. We've got a
traffic generator.
It's a web app front end. There's a
author service and a book service. And so
we'll be
injecting
we will be injecting errors
into
the,
Books app calls themselves.
This is kind of an interesting tutorial because
it uses a primitive called traffic split,
which is also how we do the canary
rollouts.
But a traffic split basically
allows you to weight traffic. And so
the traffic coming out of
any service to books
will get split. 90%
will go directly to books, and 10% will
get sent to this fault injector that we're
gonna spin up.
Okay. So we're kinda we're taking off a
few of the features then with this tutorial,
which is Yep.
Good.
So we can probably skip the stats. Right?
Or should we just take a look at
them? So you're gonna wanna do that command
just above.
The Books app also comes with
a failure in it by default, and so
let's patch it and make it so that
it's not failing anymore so we can see
what the fault injection actually is doing.
Right. Okay. So we're faxing it so that
we can break it again. Right? Exactly.
Nice.
So what we should see when we are
on the stat here, this has just given
us just a little bit of confidence that
we're gonna get that success rate back up
to
to a %?
Eventually.
Eventually. Again, status on Prometheus and so it'll
take a while for that all to fall
off.
Okay. Well, books and web app are going
down, but offers went up. So maybe we
just need to get that a little bit
of time.
Yep.
Alright. Let's see what we're supposed to do
next. So we wanna create a faulty
back end. So to do this,
we're
creating an NGINX config that returns five hundreds
and
deploying it.
Yep. Right. Got it.
So let's get this copy. Is very complicated.
And
this is just going to always return a
500 for any request that comes through it.
Yeah. The so the nginx config here, I
mean, it's just saying always return a 500.
Right. And we just we're just that's deployment
of services just
to deploy that NGINX config. Right? It's mean
there's nothing Right. Particularly interesting there. But you
could imagine making this
NGINX config so that it returns
malformed
responses or error codes other than 500 or,
you know, randomly returns
responses.
And so the testing is pretty extensive that
you could do with this kind of a
pattern.
It composes really well. Ah, okay.
This traffic split
is the service mesh interface component Mhmm. That
allows us to say whenever someone requests
the book service, we're going to Mhmm. Gather
90% of the request for the working 110%
through the error injector.
Yep.
I can read you all. Okay.
So that that is my spec just means
that it should work on any service measure.
This is not Linkerd specific at this moment
in time. Is is that right? At this
moment in time. Is is that right? As
long as your service mesh implements this CRD,
yes.
And
let's see.
Console,
Istio,
and traffic
all implement that spec
along with Linkerd.
Though sometimes it requires components. Like with Istio,
you would need to install a extra component.
Oh, and
the open service mesh from Microsoft also implements
traffic splits.
Okay. So I'm just
I I think we're being too nice here.
So
let's make things properly feel. So we'll just
bump that up.
Okay.
So that means
let me go back to this instead of
guessing all the time.
Okay. I'm not what what does this do?
I'm not sure I'm understanding that from first
sight.
So
along with being able to look at the
metrics on a per service basis, we also
allow you to look on them look at
them on a per route basis. So if
you tell us what routes you have, we
will collect metrics on those. This is just
kind of showing off that you can do
that. We haven't told
the
control plane about what those metrics what those
routes are, so we won't see a ton.
But this will give us the, two. So
what this is saying on some level is
the web app deployment
when it sends requests to the books service.
Let's take a look at those metrics.
Ah, okay.
So the Linkerd CLI is pretty much providing
a lot of really cool visibility features here
into our applications.
This one might be
interesting.
Why don't we do a stat
on deploy
web app? Or but that actually shows it
right there. We can see that the books
service has got a 20 50% success rate,
and the web app has a 2025%
success rate. So that actually gives us pretty
good details right there.
So why did the roots command not
give us anything there?
I'm I would need to go dig into
it. We're on the edge, and I'm wondering
if there's a unique configuration
issue that we need to look into there.
Okay. I wonder if I just set the
error rate too higher if I'm I'm messing
with it, but we'll move on.
So
yeah. Okay. Let me run that stat again.
Okay. So yeah. So we can see the
50% give or take error rate then within
the booked service. Mhmm. Excellent. Okay.
I mean,
so that was it. That that fault injection
this this
traffic split
was our fault injection.
Mhmm. So
the fault injection can be that's not necessarily
something specifically that Linkerd is providing like, you
know, to mock HTTP responses. It's something I
can just configure my own use case, my
own faults, and then split the traffic across
that. There's quite a lot more flexibility there
than
Linkerd is saying, oh, I'm gonna respond but
that that's 400 for x percentage. Right.
One
of the big themes for us as a
project is kind of doing composition,
giving you the primitives that you need to
go build higher level kind of concepts.
I can write a NGINX config to do
fault injection that does insane things,
and it's just some a bunch of functionality
we don't really ever want to implement in
Linkerd because it complicates and adds complexity and
makes it harder for everyone to use.
Okay.
With regards to this traffic split then,
this is also how you would do the
canary deploy, or is there something on top
of that that would be provided?
So
that's the primitive that we provide. There's a
CNCF project called Flagger that is absolutely fantastic
that then goes and does the orchestration of
the Canary,
rollout because
a Canary would wouldn't just split the traffic
ten ninety. It would split the traffic ten
ninety and then watch the
metrics until they make sure they're successful and
then slowly increase the traffic split until it's
a % on the new version.
Okay.
And I'm assuming the back ends list on
this traffic split,
right now we're doing two, but there's no
reason that it could be more? Mhmm. Okay.
Nice.
Okay. I can see a lot of different
use cases for that kind of feature then.
Yep. We use traffic split pretty heavily on
our multi cluster stuff as well.
Awesome. Hopefully, we have a little bit of
time to take a look at that.
Okay. So we're
got this amazing cloud native application.
We all got the ability to do a
canary deploys and traffic traffic splitting, traffic shaping,
whatever we wanna call that.
What about the retries and the timers then?
So we've got a
tutorial for that.
There should be a link at the top
there
if we wanna go and
configure the retries.
Ah, there we go.
So
this is
See if I can work this out.
Ah, so if you see the link there
right above retries, check out the retries section
of the Books demo.
So we've already got the Books app running
there. If you scroll
up, what we're gonna need to do is
add the
service profile.
So scroll down a little bit.
Keep on going.
It's a section titled service profile.
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
Nope. Scroll up. It's the it's the literally
that section right there. Okay. Okay. So there
we go. So the service profiles are
I kind of hinted that you need to
tell us what routes you have, and the
reason for that is that
cardinality is the cluster
killer.
The more cardinality you have, the bigger your
Prometheus gets. The bigger your Prometheus gets, the
slower your cluster gets. And so we need
you to tell us what
routes you've got. We can consume,
Swagger or open API specifications
and, gRPC proto buffs. We've also got a
couple other commands to go and help you
build out those service profiles. But why don't
we grab the Swagger profile here for the
Books app and
generate a service profile for that and then
apply it to the cluster?
Okay. I'm just gonna take a look at
what this
output.
Okay. So a service profile. Okay. It's just
a list of the roots then. Yep.
That are rejects. Yeah. That's about it.
I always suspect to like be revealed by
some massive complexity thing and then you're like,
oh, it's just YAML. Always YAML.
Okay. It's YAML all the way down. Yeah.
It really is. In fact, the service profile
was right there in the docs and I
just wasn't looking at it. Okay. Perfect.
So now that we have a service profile,
do I need to run this as well?
Yeah. Let's add profiles for the other two
services, the
author service and the book service.
And then we can verify that with the
tap command.
So what do we have here?
That's showing us the
route. So if you see the path there.
Yes.
There we go. Alright. Path.
Is that right? Mhmm.
Is
there an r t underscore route in there
somewhere?
I'm not seeing it.
We might be running into some
bleeding edge issues. Oh, no.
It's there. I see it.
Oh, there. Yep. Okay. Cool. So that's,
the name of each of the routes in
the service profile shows up there. And so
if you wanted to put a fancy name
in instead of just post books ID edit,
you could do that.
Okay. So we've
added we've we've told Linkerd that each of
our services has a Swagger file. We created
a service profile based on that Swagger file.
Now how do I tell it to do
retries?
Straight to the retries.
So if you see, we've got a edit
command down
a couple steps there.
So if we run that edit there.
Okay. And then we're gonna make an edit
to the root. So we have so we
have to okay.
So let me see if I if I
understand this correctly then. So when we enable
the sidecar injection on our pods,
we have to still apply service profiles and
have retriable. So it's not something that the
sidecar just does by default and it sees
some sort of http error and the thing
like we we have to be very explicit
about the way that we want that to
function.
Exactly. And that is because
not all routes you want to retry.
Imagine having a credit card
charge getting retried a thousand times. That would
be pretty bad.
There's also, retries with great,
with
great power becomes great responsibility.
Retries really are a great tool, but it's
something you need to be very conscious about
turning on. And so that's
kind of where we are here. You really
can only do them for,
item potent requests, so anything that's not got
a body, get head, that kind of thing.
And you really only wanna do it when
you're %
confident that that's the thing that you want
to do. So that's why we have you
attach it on a per route basis.
And now, obviously, because these service profiles are
regexes,
you could write a dot star regex
for your service profile and then retry everything.
I wouldn't recommend that, but it's something that
you could do.
Would it be possible to I'm assuming with
the regex, it would be. Right? I could
just match an old get request and assume
that a get request is not gonna have
any sort of mutation on the server side,
and that's probably okay to be Exactly. Retried.
Okay. Again,
I would strongly
not recommend that, but it's doable.
Okay.
So let's it keeps opening in my other
window. So let's just
alright.
And we want
to just add this as retriable here.
So Specifically to that author's
line. Yeah.
Which author's
hedge request. Okay.
This one here.
Yep.
Done. Yep.
That was painless.
So
let's
see what this tells us now.
So
this might be our issue with the
edge. I don't understand why we're not getting
stats here. But if you go back and
take a look at the docs, we'll see
what the output is supposed to look like
at least.
And so here, we're showing you the effective
success and the actual success, which is
pretty cool. This is the difference. The
retries gets your effective success up from the
actual because we're retrying, but it has the
downside of increasing latency.
Now is this
edge bug that we're we're running into something
that's only do we think that's likely only
to be affecting this command? Like, if I
put forward to the dashboard or to the
confana, would we be able to get a
more visual look at that?
This would be the right command to see
this data. So
and it's all getting pulled from Prometheus, so
I don't think we'll have a more visual
way to take a look at that. Alright.
Okay. No worries.
So, okay. I think we understand retries there.
I'm gonna assume timeouts are pretty much in
the exact same vein. We find
the path that we want to
apply our realtor. Yeah. And we we add
on the timeout. So
Yep. We won't we won't run through that.
Let's see what else we can quickly do
then.
So is there anything that you're particularly drawn
to that you'd like to move on to
Nick?
That's a good question.
Why don't just for fun, why don't we
go and do the
it is let me make sure I can
find docs here.
Let's go to
the securing your service doc.
Alright. Let's go. It's
under
feet it's under tasks. So if you click
the task link there,
down towards the bottom, there is a securing
your service.
Okay. And so sorry, Anigo. Oh, yeah. So,
we do MTLS,
by default out of the box with Linkerd.
We actually make it really hard for you
to turn off.
Encryption is great,
but it's a little hard to validate. And
so this doc will kind of walk us
through using,
not just or pretty much all the Linkerd
tools and
a couple lower level ones to go and
validate that MTLS is really working between all
of the nodes.
So MTLS is already running on the pods
that I've enabled the sidecar on?
Yeah. Ah, okay.
MTLS,
like I said, is enabled out of the
box.
In fact,
tap, the command we've been talking about that,
Wireshark for your cluster,
requires,
m t l s because we need the
identity to validate that some rando isn't making
calls on your cluster to get all of
the traffic going through it. Okay. So that
that just means that all of the requests
that leave my pods are being encrypted for
me and I've not had to do it
at then. Exactly.
I mean, I'm sold already on that feature.
I I I thought we were gonna have
to go enable something but the fact that
that's just no because I just installed Linkerd
and injected the second, that's pretty awesome.
So you said it's hard for us to
confirm that that works but not impossible.
Right?
I mean, how how do I know that
that I just trust it?
Well, that was my point. Let's go and
take the steps.
I don't trust it.
Alright. Let's see what this command is gonna
return.
Alright. So that's
okay. All of those are secured. We we
have our favorite little green tech here.
So,
yes, I see the output.
Awesome.
And we can run the tap again.
And it's suggesting
is there anything at the top that would
suggest it's encrypted? Or is Yeah. So you
see the TLS equals there?
So there's TLS not provided by remote. That's
not encrypted.
But if there's TLS equals true, then it
is encrypted.
Ah.
And so you'll see some commands there that
aren't encrypted. Those are ones we can't. If
it's coming from the Kubelet, that's not injected
with the Linkerd proxy.
We don't control both sides of the connection.
But anything that's a request between two services,
we definitely can.
That's where you see the TLS true.
Okay. That makes sense.
So we can validate MTLS
with
t sharp.
And this is the like,
don't just take our word for it with
all of the tools that Linkerd has put
together. This actually adds a debugging container
to your sidecar that adds,
or it adds a
debugging container to your pod that you can
then go and run debugging tools on. We
use it a lot to go and debug
the service mesh itself, but this is a
great way to see the, like, raw
bytes as they go through and make sure
that they are actually encrypted.
Awesome.
Okay. Let's just reapply that. So it's
okay. So it's injected that. Okay. So it's
updated the sidecar with the debug option then
on each of those deployment.
Specifically, it's added an annotation
that will go and add another
pod
or another container to the pod,
which is that debug container.
Alright. Let's spend the deployment.
Yeah. Okay. So it just enabled debug sig
capture.
Good. Because that means it's quite easy for
me to add that then without the actual
Linkerd inject aspect. Exactly.
So then we can get a remote shell
by jumping and say one jumping inside of
that debug container and our emoji portal voting
service.
Mhmm.
And t shark.
And T Shark is just a command line
Wireshark. We're gonna be looking at the port
eighty eighty and
taking a look at SSL and then looking
at what's going on on local host.
And if a not local host. Right? Right.
Okay.
So it's actually it's looking specifically for requests
which are leaving the service to another service,
which is where the MTLS boundaries are, I
guess. So this is actually coming in, but
it's coming in on the proxy,
e g,
the
exterior IP address, not the interior IP address.
Because the way that service meshes work is
that we have some IP tables games that
go and redirect all of the incoming traffic
into the proxy that then forwards it to
the local host.
And so if we were to look at
local hosts, we would actually see everything
in clear text. But as you can see
here, we've got nothing but
TLS data going through
except for that ready, which is, again,
the
Kubelet calling in and validating that our service
is up.
Yeah. The the SYNACK packets. Right? These Mhmm.
Yeah. Okay.
Okay. That's pretty sweet. I like that.
Nice.
And that that's it. So we've covered
retries,
timers with Xenbin, MTLS.
I mean and that was
safe to say that was all pretty trivial.
Mhmm. That does not really require too much
effort on my part which is good otherwise
it would all have been wrong.
So I'm really happy with that. That's great.
Now
shall we is the
on a home page,
we have this big deal about the multi
cluster Kubernetes thing. Mhmm. Is that something we're
gonna be to look at with the one
nineteen, or do you think we may run
into some issues with that?
We can definitely give it a try. We
changed the way that multicluster works, so we're
actually going to need to go and take
a look at the
pull requests on the docs website if we
want to get that one up and up
and running.
But we can definitely give it a try
and see what happens there.
Sure. Why not? Let's see what happens.
So if you go to
let me find
those docs too.
So I'm assuming I'll need to go through
the standard install Linkerd command on my other
cluster. Right? Oh, so,
actually, what you're gonna wanna do is
uninstall
Linkerd
from
your current cluster and then do a reinstall.
And the reason for that is that to
get multicluster
up and running, we need to have a
common trust anchor.
And the the reason for that is that
the trust anchor,
is how we do authentication
so that users can't randos can't be requesting
services inside your cluster.
And so,
actually, what you're gonna wanna do is
Just change this to the gonna send
you a link
because
it's probably going to be easiest that way.
Give me just a second here. Yeah. Of
course.
That is gonna be the
docs for that.
Okay. So should I
first do the Linkerd install, but delete path
to get rid of all this? So I
would do an uninstall.
Oh,
that's easy.
Uninstall and then pipe that into
kubectl delete.
And since we've got those two other namespaces,
you probably want to clean up the emoji
photo and book sat namespaces.
The reason
why we need to do an uninstall here
is that we
install a couple API services, which are Kubernetes
resources.
And if you delete a namespace and have
an API service running, Kubernetes loses its little
mind. And so,
you definitely wanna do that, but you can
just delete the namespaces for Books app and
Emoji photo.
Was thinking about completing it. Maybe I should
just detect it.
Yeah. Okay.
Delete it. Let's fill up these docs.
Well, eventually delete it. I have
confidence. So
we're going
way off script then.
Way off script.
Oh, in fact, so way way off strip
script that the
command that I thought was in there to
cut and paste stuff is not there. Let
me
give you that command real quick.
So is that a command I have to
run before the multicluster install, or can I
go ahead and just start it? Well,
so the multicluster install is only gonna install
the multicluster components.
What you're gonna wanna do is
click on the if you scroll up on
that dock a little bit,
you'll see that you require two clusters and
a control plane installation that shares a common
trust anchor. So click on the, trust anchor
link there,
and we're going to create a
trust anchor certificate.
I would recommend doing a brew install step
here.
But if you are a
crazy
OpenSSL
Kung Fu artist,
I won't stop you.
No.
Brew install step dash
CLI.
I can always quickly look that up.
It's just step, I think.
Cool.
And I'm assuming established as some sort of
utility for generating
x five zero nine certificate or something similar.
Yeah. It's actually a great CLI that does
a lot more than that, but we use
it just for generating the certificates.
Okay.
So
we
So that created a trust anchor. And
then you're gonna wanna go and
do the step certificate
and create a
issuer certificate. So there is
a,
trust anchor that goes and installs that kind
of maintains is a CA and maintains the
trust across your two clusters. And then, theoretically,
though, we don't need to do it here.
You would have an issuer cert that you
rotate on a regular basis that's
actually what the proxies get their certificates from.
Okay. That's this is making sense to me
now. The fact that we're gonna do multi
cluster means so we we need a CA
that is trusted on both for the communication
to be effectively
encrypted across that boundary.
Can I do I mean, do I have
to use something here? Could this work into
tools like Vault to provide that top level
CA?
Well, so this is an unfortunate
colocation of terms. There is a type of
certificate that is a CA certificate,
and then there is a type of service
that is an online CA.
So you can use Vault to go and
get the certificates if you wanted to,
but this is just a way to add
them yourself.
While the
trust anchor needs to be generated,
we also allow you to do automatic cert
rotation with cert manager if you so wanted
to do that. Oh, sweet. Okay.
So is my next step just to keep
following through with this? Yep. Alright. And so
that'll install it on
one cluster, and so you'll wanna then just
select the context that you want for the
other cluster.
All the things.
All the things all over again.
Alright. So kube config equals
Linkerd
two dot JSON.
Let's see if that works. We'll see if
we got created or configured.
Alright. Let's just do this.
And then reapply that command.
Okay.
So we have Linkerd configured with our trust
anchor
deployed to cluster one and cluster two. I'm
assuming
we can skip this helm and jump That
was just a alternative for him. Actually, just
go back, and we should be able to
continue the docs as they are laid out.
Okay. So now we're doing the multicluster installed
to each cluster. Mhmm. Alright. So let's just
do cluster two first.
I should just split this, shouldn't I? That'd
a bit easier.
Linkerd two,
then do d one, and then do Linkerd
one.
Alright.
So we
have
a check command. I love these check commands.
And we got all the green ticks.
Good.
So we've not linked the clusters yet.
So
See if I can work with that. So
what's the context and and this context?
So
you probably won't need to worry about the
context here. This is kind of from a
blog post that we've got that talks about
two different clusters, the East cluster and the
West cluster, and kind of walks you through
things.
You'll wanna delete the context
from this one, but the idea here is
is that you're gonna run the Linkerd CLI
on your Linkerd one cluster.
That's going to the multicluster link is going
from the
excuse me. Let me come at this from
a different angle. When you run Linkerd multi
cluster link on Linkerd cluster
one,
going to output all of the, required
configuration
for Linkerd cluster two to talk to Linkerd
cluster one.
And so what you're gonna wanna do is
run the Linkerd multi cluster link
on cluster one, get the YAML, and then
apply that YAML to cluster two.
Got it. Okay. So I can modify this
in line. So let me pull this along.
So instead of context east here, which is
just a Kubernetes config, I can leave that
blank which is just in cluster one
and we give this a name. So can
I just call this Linkerd one? Yep. And
then here, we're actually just gonna point it
to the other cube config,
I guess.
Yep.
Linkerd
two
dot JSON.
And that's gonna link cluster one to cluster
two.
Right.
What did I get wrong?
Let's it says no objects passed to apply.
There might have been an error there.
K. What's the
No ingress.
So the problem there is that we need
to have a load balancer with an IP
address
public IP address so these two clusters can
talk to each other.
So this is saying that we don't have
a gateway address there yet. So why don't
we run
kubectl
on the
Linkerd dash multi cluster namespace and look at
the services,
figure out what's going on there,
dash multi cluster?
So we're still waiting for you to get
a external IP address.
Which will never work.
Uh-oh.
Yeah. So this is a
bare metal cluster that needs a very special
type of load balancer either QVIP
or metal l b. Let me quickly
grab
that
and see if I can get that working
in under a minute. And if not, we
will abort.
Cool.
Okay.
So let's see.
So the while you're doing that, let me
kind of explain what's going on here.
We've actually got a blog post that talks
a lot about it.
In,
our experience,
when you start talking about multiple clusters of
Kubernetes,
it is, very unlikely that they can route
to each other.
Imagine having
a cluster in two different cloud providers, for
example.
Having a flat routable network is basically impossible.
And, I mean, you can do it. It
just requires a whole bunch of effort. And
so what we do is rely on
services with load balancer IPs that are public
and routable, and then we can just,
pass traffic through those those gateways into your
cluster.
And so you don't need to think about
any low level networking here. It just gets
an external
IP address in most cloud providers, and you're
good to go.
So I did install
QVIP.
But to be honest, I am not sure
if I'm gonna need to be able to
set that up with anything.
Let's see if I can see anything immediately
in the logs and if not.
But data like leader.
And we should have
a CCM.
Cloud controller
running.
I think we may
we
we'll give it we'll give it thirty seconds.
May get an IP address. In fact, I
could probably
take a look here and see if we
have thing.
Yeah. Potentially.
So normally there would be one elastic guy.
Oh no. Because I have two clusters. Okay.
They're maybe not gonna get one then.
Drats.
Bummer. Failed. Oh, well.
It doesn't matter. Like, that would have been
cool to show off, but I didn't think
about the ingress aspect of it. So next
time, I'll definitely get that working.
Cool. Yeah. I'm I'm sorry. I didn't even
think about
giving you heads up on that one.
Well, I guess you wouldn't have to. Right?
Normally, not a problem. Cloud providers have this
little add on that that works with the
load balancer service type. Unfortunately, bare metal just
as a little bit different and does require
a little bit of upfront work. I could
have installed metal l b, cube dip. I
think with cube up actually, I need to
tell it the elastic IP that it has
control of so they can pass that
And then I just don't have that config
and I keep randomly heading that going, maybe
it'll just magically come into fruition. But it's
not gonna happen.
Anyway, I think that's great. Is there anything
else quickly you wanna go over before we
wrap up with that you think would be
cool to show off?
No. I think that's pretty good.
We've kind of covered
most of the feature set, to be honest.
Yeah. I mean, there was a lot going
on there. And again, it was really trivial,
really easy to play with. I I just
like how intuitive
the the CLI was itself and how easy
it was to work through the documentation.
Like it was just well, it was a
pleasure to work with actually. Good. Thank you.
Well, I wanted to say thank you very
much for joining me, taking the time out
of your day to come and show us
Linkerd. I'm looking forward to exploring and playing
with it more. It's a really cool tool
and service mesh like we, you know, we
we touched a little better on this just
why would I want this thing in my
cluster, you know, with the complexities that we're
pushing down from the software layer
And I think Linkerd plays a big part
of that. Thank you for joining me. Have
a great day and I will hopefully speak
to you again soon. Awesome. Alright. Bye.